le ton monte entre les salariés et la
direction de carambar depuis plusieurs
semaines une grève a été lancé et
l'entreprise tourne au ralenti en cause
la délocalisation de cette usine
historique construite en 1899
sur le site de lüthi à quelques
kilomètres de là dans la ville de
bondues pour les habitants de la commune
de marcq en baroeul
difficile d'imaginer une journée sans
odeur de caramel pourtant cette décision
prise en novembre dernier n'est pas le
vrai problème des salariés alors que les
sites comprend 114 salariés seuls 105
postes seront reconduits à bondues 6 9
salariés sont donc dans le flou quant à
leur avenir dans l'entreprise pour ce
qui reste c'est la douche froide
la direction a annoncé une baisse de
salaire pouvant aller jusqu'à -25%
selon les syndicats une honte selon
andré joris salariés de l'usiné et
secrétaire du ce et s on se sert d'une
crise économique pour pour faire un peu
n'importe le courant les patrons sont un
peu en roue libre en ce moment il
profite de cet état de fait et on en
paye les pots cassés
il s'était engagé sur certains points
ils sont revenus en arrière hier ils ont
même enlevé des choses qu'ils étaient
sur plan social c'est un plan social qui
ne ne délivre pas d'argent actuellement
à l'heure actuelle il ne livre rien
c'est une honte c'est un scandale on est
en train de bâcher les salariés donc
c'est les gens ils empochent celui-ci
honnêtement 1
si notre si nos directions du synode pdg
s'obstine comme sahin continue à
s'obstiner comme ça pas écouter les
salariés
j'ai peur qu'au bout d'un moment où l'on
peut voir disparaître de carambar une
disparition de la célèbre barre
caramélisées catastrophique pour cette
entreprise seuls au monde à fabriquer
cette confiserie
chaque année ce sont sept mille cinq
cents tonnes de caramel qui sortent de
l'usiné de marcq en baroeul
du côté des salariés plusieurs
propositions ont été faites selon andré
joris notamment une indemnité pour
compenser la perte des salaires bruts
des propositions rejetées par la
direction présents sur le site ce
vendredi adrien 80 ce député la france
insoumise de la première circonscription
du nord a tenu à soutenir ses salariés
on observe c'est que la situation de la
pandémie va détruire des emplois de
manière assez considérable le fc eux
estiment que d'ici à fin 2021 ça
pourrait être quelques 800 mille emplois
qui vont disparaître et dans le même
temps on voit qu'il ya deux choses il ya
les entreprises qui pâtissent vraiment
la crise et à celles qui profitent de la
situation aussi il faut le dire est
souvent d'ailleurs de l'entreprise qui
ont bénéficié des aides publiques de
l'état il faut le rappeler
donc on pourrait imaginer par exemple
puisque notre président de la république
a dit qu'on était en temps de guerre en
2020 en france lé milliardaire français
en pleine pandémie ont engrangé 175
milliards de plus ces deux fois le
budget annuel de l'hôpital public
ne peut-on pas imaginer une contribution
exceptionnelle dans la période de
pandémie qui pourrait venir notamment au
renfort des entreprises en difficulté et
premier chef des salariés en grève
depuis le 10 décembre dernier les
salariés de cette usine ne décolère pas
et souhaitent comprendre la raison de
cette baisse de salaire pour un poste
équivalent pour obtenir des réponses nos
équipes ont tenté de joindre la
direction en vain à ce jour